on Monday you probably heard about this
Chase Bank was roundly criticized for an
insensitive tweet they sent using the
popular hashtag Monday motivation here's
the tweet they sent out you why is my
balance so low bank account make coffee
at home bank account eat the food that's
already in the fridge bank account you
don't need a cab it's only three blocks
you I guess we'll never know bank
account seriously hashtag Monday
motivation well people were upset Chase
was accused of shaming its poorer
customers so Chase took the tweet down
what we looked into it and people may
have been a little harsh on Chase see
Chase is not the only company to misuse
the Monday motivation hashtag to insult
their customers check out these tweets
we found for example this is real I hop
tweeted enough cholesterol to end your
crap life soon stack them high lose
their hashtag Monday motivation yeah yes
uber sweeted wondering what kind of job
you can get with a liberal arts degree
meets your uber driver
hashtag monday motivation the gap
tweeted we love it when old navy
customers lose 15 pounds so they can fit
into gap clothes hashtag monday
motivation Hair Club for Hair Club for
Men tweeted your head looks like half a
scrotum deal with it hashtag Monday
motivation twits Twix tweeted eat one
bar now and save the other bar for nine
seconds from now human trash can
hashtag Monday motivation to greed
deodorant tweeted instead of smelling
like a pig today why not smell like a
pig wearing deodorant
hashtag Monday motivation Eminem's
tweeted just pretend they're sleeping
pills and go to town playing Monday
motivation and finally this was crazy
Jamba Juice tweeted piss out the last
the beer put on some clean sweats and
put some healthy in your body you fat
bag JAMA do
[Applause]